gonna spend this lesson and last lesson
the final lesson of the day on it um i
remember you
i i'm remembering number one when i did
radio measure at the end of year ten and
number two
all the times i've taught radio measure
um you guys know how it's crammed at the
end of the year
and you've got all four of these weirdo
topics that are really hard to
understand right
um all of you from different classes
right but i don't know about you most
people
i think feel quite rushed as they go
through radian measure and
you're just trying to wrap your brain
around this idea of okay why should we
um
have this form of measurement for angles
um how do you use it for circles and
tones and sections and blah blah blah so
i'm sort of going to treat this lesson
uh excuse me as a fresh introduction to
the topic
okay so then we can actually get into
the uh
practicalities of using all of these um
rules for measuring things which are
sort of rounded circular
okay so here's my first question to you
um and it's going to lead into what this
weird diagram is
i wonder what it looks like actually to
you because i have a very clear picture
in my head what it is but
why a new way of measuring angles
why and you i mean we've been using
degrees
for like four and whatever years or
longer than that i suppose if you were
doing it from
primary school we've been using degrees
for quite a while
and we've been quite happy with them
right so
why do we have to go to all this trouble
of introducing a new way of measuring
angles
okay that's my question
yeah and especially because you have to
deal with this weird pie business like
at least you've got whole numbers
okay so in order to answer that question
why a new way
of measuring angles um i want to pose a
question before that which is
why the old wave why is it that we we
take a revolution
right and we divide it into 360 degrees
where does that come from anyone got any
ideas why 360.
okay yes so we're doing that circles
here good that's a step in the vibration
you might think it has to do with um
something to do with ratios in a circle
okay because circles are what we would
get angles from
right they're these kinds of shapes
right however
even though i think we're on the right
track there doesn't answer the question
why 360.
why not if you're a european engineer
why not use
these why not break it up into a sort of
decimal
number on your calculator you've got
degrees uh radians and gradients
which divide a revolution into 400 of
them so why not that
seems like a better number to use it's
metric it's decimal
y360 any other suggestions
yeah good 360 is no ordinary number
right how many factors does 360 have uh
a lot let's see one
two three four five
six seven's a bit of a pain admittedly
but uh is the division by eight
yeah yes uh it's divisible by nine
ten uh not eleven twelve
you can keep going from there right
that's pretty good right like as numbers
go
okay certainly certainly better than if
you pick like 351
okay i can't divide that into anything
so all right so it's convenient
it's convenient if you want to break
things up into intersections which with
circles i suppose we sometimes do
but apart from that can you come up with
any other reasons
now um i will tell you who came up with
360.
it's a very old number ancient
civilizations came up with it but it was
not just any one of those ancient
civilizations
um it was does anyone know
on romanies the greeks the minoans a
whole variety of
societies have used the same 360.
different cultures um but it was always
the same people within those cultures
who came up with the 360 and the answer
was not who you'd think
it was it was the sailors
always the sailors now what do sailors
have to do with this diagram
okay you're out at sea you're on a boat
okay
um and if you want to know where you are
as a sailor you have a problem that
normal like a you know a horse
rider or uh someone who's just walking
along doesn't have this problem
you look around you're like where am i
and you're surrounded by what kind of
landmarks
nothing because there's no land to have
landmarks right
so you've just got water around you okay
but you do have something you do have
something it's not around you
it's above you right so sailors all knew
okay we can look at the stars and that
gives us a general idea of where we are
because
the stars are quite static like you look
at them and you're like oh
they're still they're the same as they
were last night right
no not quite almost almost but not quite
um here's my diagram representation of
a part of the stars that you might see
as you look around the universe
okay now i've only drawn a part of it
because if i drew everything
i wouldn't be able to illustrate
anything okay so
the the kinds of stars that you see over
here they actually do change
a little bit every night why do they
change
okay um here's here's the earth okay
there's a terrible scale i know but
anyway
okay and because because
um one side is facing the sun and one
side is not
okay this is the the night side and this
is the day side
okay so fast forward to like 10 o'clock
tonight
and we're going to be on on this side
and when you look out to see the stars
okay because the earth is facing in one
direction
which stars
which stars will you see well as you
look out right let me get another color
you will see um a sort of bunch of
stars that sort of correspond to here if
you look sort of further out i guess the
further stars you can see would be over
there
but obviously you can't see stars that
are behind
the earth does that make sense um on the
opposite side on the day side
okay now as you guys know um the earth
doesn't sit still in its position around
the sun
it moves it orbits okay so it's moving
around
in this kind of fashion okay again very
realistic right
so when i go to a different spot like
say here
okay so again the earth got fatter
anyway
the night side of the earth is facing a
different direction
right so i'm going to see
different stars okay now how long does
it take to go all the way around
back to the start yeah
365 and a quarter actually it's not
quite that but it's pretty close
um days right uh night
morning night sorry day night tackles
yeah okay
um so the sailors worked out okay look
as you look up i'm trying to look for
some sort of fixed point so i can know
where i am okay
it's almost fixed it's not quite it
changes a little
bit each night as i look up right
but when you go about 360 times
360 nights around and you know journeys
along the c they do take a long time
right
that's when you get back to the start
you've got the same set of stars over
here
okay now because this um you know
sailors knew
that you've got this uh orbiting around
the sun okay
they knew they're not just moving in a
straight line the earth is not moving a
straight line that's why it comes back
to its original position
so they knew that as they change from
position to position
it's a rotational change it's not like
sort of the earth
is um heading along in a single
direction
okay and that's why the kind of stars
that it can see
will be different they knew it was
rotation so they said okay
this rotational difference right
i will call that our degree and by the
way degree is just a general word
like you know we use it for all kinds of
things because when things go up a
degree
we mean they're increasing so we use
them for temperature as well as for
angles
and when they wanted more precision they
just said well let's break that up into
mining portions
right hence hence minutes right okay
now we sort of lucked out okay as a
planet because
um we talked about this the ratio
between how many
how long it takes to go around the sun
and how many times
time how long it takes to spin around
right it's about 365 okay so
it's pretty close to a nice handy number
okay but if you're on a different planet
mercury venus jupiter anything right
the ratio between the rotation and the
orbit will be different
so you'd come up with a different number
at least if you were sailing on the
oceans and venus there's no nothing else
really has oceans
actually i think jupiter has some moons
with oceans but anyway that's another
story
so but here's the key here's the key
okay this 360
was just lucky i was just lucky in fact
it's not really even 360. okay it was
just close enough for sales to say
all right that's a good measure okay
so um this 360 degrees number one
this is my first reason it was a lucky
measurement from sailors
okay from another planet it'd be
different okay
but number two whose perspective
is this measure measured from who's
perspective maybe that's not even a
question
about uh it's from the perspective of
sailor isn't it
the idea is that as you look up at the
stars if you turn your head
just a little bit okay um a degree
okay that's how much the stars are
changing from time to time
so it's from the perspective of an
observer
right watching something that's spinning
around
and trying to describe that change okay
now
for these two reasons this is why
degrees actually do not work very well
when you start to do real maths um when
you start to do stuff like say trig this
is why we're trying to introduce it
together with
tree and radian measure okay so